thank you
for uh talking to me about it and for
making this and i'm curious
kyle for you i mean how did you come to
this
how how is this presented to you because
it seems like
such an insane idea
um that's a really good question
christina when i was initially
uh approached by chris and some of the
other people on
the we the people like team people that
were in charge of making this thing
happen
and they came to me with the opportunity
to
help educate the youth right that was
sort of how they were
explaining it to me at first and you
know i have always wanted to help people
with my music
and this idea seemed really
epic and like the the coolest way i
could possibly
possibly do that you know i can help
educate people who may listen to me
about ways they can be involved as like
an american citizen in their country
you know so yeah for me it was it was a
no-brainer when i was first approached
with it i was like
yes because this will make an actual
like lasting imprint on
any young person that needs to know what
the difference between state and federal
government is
the same way when i watched like
schoolhouse rock as a kid and i finally
learned what a bill was
you know so uh yeah for me it was it was
a no-brainer to
to jump on on board and being a part of
this at the same time could you ever
have imagined that
at any point in your career you'd get to
a place where you were performing a song
about federal versus state power
never never that was the
most rewarding part about it is you know
i
i was doing something that i've never i
was writing a song about a topic i've
never
never ever talked about and a topic i
didn't even necessarily know that much
about
and that right there was the the reason
to do it you know i was like wow i don't
even know that much about this
so imagine you know all the other kids
and people out there that also need to
be educated
i'm one of them so if i educate myself
and put these lyrics into a song
that is hopefully a really catchy and
good song i can blast it out to the
world
and hopefully a lot of other people will
become educated on the topic
tim what was this like for you as far as
when you got involved with it did you
know that
you would get to do different animation
styles that
did you have any idea what song you
would be working with in the beginning
yeah so i was uh supervising director
across all 10 episodes
and then specifically directed this
episode with kyle
um and uh early on when i was brought on
the project they were kind of debating
hey should these all be different styles
this should be one style i said hey this
should be different we got
you know if you're gonna have somebody
doing kind of folk country music like
brandy carlisle you're gonna have
somebody doing show tunes like the
lopez's
and lin-manuel you're gonna have folks
like kyle and cordee
and janelle monae you just we're just
this is all different kinds of music
and all of those artists are going to be
pulling their own style out of the bag
right
so we got to liberate our directors in
the same way
and you know big part of what we're
trying to represent here is the
diversity of what america is right we're
trying to get across
the specifics of how our government
works but a lot of that we want to put
on screen is like
hey there's a lot of variety of voices
and types of people here in the in this
country so
part of the big piece of that was let's
make sure that the stylistically we're
always moving around too
this series combines two of my favorite
things with music and animation
but tim for you i mean how how
challenging is it to approach
capturing politics and social change
with one song
having three minutes of animation as a
director is that just completely
daunting
i mean the daunting part is working with
the obamas and working with kyle and
working with janelle monae and working
with
lin-manuel so that's the daunting part
conveying information i'm pretty used to
i've done that enough times that i'm
like all right i can do this
but yeah doing it with those folks and
trying to match that level of
you know you know people are going to be
watching people are going to be paying
attention so you got to really
put in the effort and make it something
great um
and then also make sure that it's
something that represents all of those
partners well
when you guys look at at past work like
schoolhouse rock or even like
hamilton is the trick to getting people
to learn something that might seem
dry boring or uninteresting just making
it really cool
that's exactly it you can't you can't
inform people if you don't entertain
them right
you gotta you gotta be fun to watch for
them to stick around to learn all
everything you wanna learn
i agree i think people's attention is
like if you don't have their attention
you can't give them any information so
that's like the first
key part and i think specifically in
this song kyle set us up really nicely
for that because
the personalities were so vivid for the
federal and state government and his
performance
and and the way the track was produced
everything was there for from an energy
perspective
uh so you know at that point it's like
all right
you know can we can we embellish these
characters with drawing
and then can we layer on the information
that needs to be layered on that on top
kyle what was your process for writing
this song was it something that
happened quickly for you does it make
you more focused when you know
what you're creating and what it's for
or does
everything slow down when you know
you're doing a project that the obamas
are involved in
yeah everything definitely slows down
especially
for this specific song um usually when
i'm as a songwriter i'm always trying to
be honest
and i'm trying to uh be honest speak my
truth and also just make something fun
and with this one it was
particularly a little more challenging
because i had to make sure that what i
was saying was like
you know uh correct accurate information
you know because we're really using this
to educate people so if i'm in there
saying things that may or may not be
true then
you know it kind of defeats the entire
purpose of making the record so
yeah for this thing slow way down you
know i'm like oh my god
okay barack and michelle are gonna
listen to this so
long better slap you know they have a
good taste of music
uh and on top of it you know hopefully a
bunch of kids around the world
and then our country will watch these
and learn about our government so
let me just make sure that what i'm
saying is true so there's a lot of like
self education that went into it how did
you know when you were done with the
song i mean what is
that process like for you do you know
okay this is it i'm ready it's finished
and then you
never work on it again or are you the
type of artist who
always wishes you could just keep
working on something
i always wish i could keep working on
something but i knew
this was done after i listened to the
entire song
and because it was kind of like a give
and take of just adding
all the information and then adding you
know really catchy lyrics too
and there was a point where you know i
think i had a lyric that set um
um as long as
we have our independence to keep all of
our
individual people protected it don't
matter
um what state you rest in deep down
we're still all connected
let's link up and i was like yeah that's
catchy
and it's explaining the story so that
was really what i was aiming for finding
a bunch of lyrics throughout the song
that were catchy attention grabbing felt
good to listen to
but also we're speaking to what it means
to be
you know like an individual from
california and we want things to kind of
go this way
as opposed to an individual from a state
like utah or something
you know and they want to live their
life a certain way but we all are like
contributing
to you know the bigger part of like
being one country
so after i could work some lyrics in
like that i was like okay i think i
think i'm filled with this
tim what was it like for you as
supervising director on this entire
project to see
you know to hear these songs come in to
see the animation that was being done
and everything to see how
it all came together and what these what
this finished product is looking like
now
it was unreal there were so many times
i'd be driving in my car home from work
or
out and about and i would just like
crank andra day's
song about the course up just like yeah
so good these tracks are really good so
um
you know it's just a lot of fun to have
you just kind of sitting you know
on my end of things i'm just kind of
sitting there and
these songs fall into my lap because i
wasn't part of that process
but um and just every time you're like
wow there's another great track
and so excited to get started and work
with the teams to
turn it into something visual as well so
just really really thrilling
to go from a list of subjects to then
the songs that accompanied those that
list of subjects
was it ever like really surprising or
shocking that these were just really
great
songs about just the craziest subjects
yeah it is pretty surprising
yeah just how great i mean that's i i
don't write music i don't
make music and um chris refers to it as
their superpower i
i have to agree i i don't you know it's
not
it's not a process i you know can
carry on myself so uh when they're able
to
take something like federal versus state
and make a dope track or
you know the balance of powers and make
the amazing track that they made for
that like it's
it's really impressive to condense all
the information and still have something
that has personality in life
and that you feel like you could hear on
the radio that's it takes some doing
as i mean i've always been a fan of
music my entire life and
and there's certain albums that i judge
my life as like my life before that
album came out in my life out after that
album came out
but songwriting is always like one of
those really elusive things that like
how do you ever really explain to
somebody
what that's like so does that kind of
feel
like a superpower to you
yeah nah definitely and i gotta say tim
what you do is a superpower too
um you know bringing to life the words
that we put down
um in a way that i literally the
characters from tim's video is how i
picture them
in my head we never talked about it once
you know what i mean
um so i just gotta say that was a super
power
um yeah but i view songwriting
as a superpower because you get to
nothing pierces somebody's like actual
heart
like music you know music goes
right into the person that you are and
directly makes a change on you right
then and there
when you hear a life-changing album like
you said my life before this album and
after it will change you it will add
something to
like your dna and who you are as a
person so
being able to make this song
specifically if this song can hit
somebody that same way
but also breaks down the importance of
like
you know our government to me that was
like
that right there is astonishing if i you
know if i pulled that off
um and all the other artists on here all
made amazing songs so
yeah it's definitely it definitely feels
like a superpower
could you ever see any situation
especially now that like concerts and
stuff
are coming back that you would perform
this song live oh my god
without a doubt you know i will
literally put on my
professor suit jacket break out like a
white board on stage
and start just breaking down the
difference between state and federal
government and honestly all the other
artists that worked on this are so
cool like if i could do a show with her
or janelle monae or
anybody like that that would that would
be incredible so hey just saying you
know
why not let's go on a tour you know
as you can see by all the posters on my
wall i would be
all over that because they're all music
artists
what do you guys hope that you know
lending your voice to this
will do especially for young people do
you hope that
you know not only will they get to hear
some catchy tunes and see some great
visuals that maybe they'll actually
understand some of this stuff in a way
that they
didn't before yeah i hope that
more and more people get engaged in the
political process
because i really believe that the
political process that our democracy
benefits from everybody being involved
and that's everything from voting
running from office to
volunteering and serving your community
and a big uh
focus for brock uh for the president on
this project was
hey let's hit that that age group that
is just about to start voting that is
just about to start really feeling their
political power and um
educate them so that when they're 18
they're ready to vote they want to do it
and when they're
you know ready to get out there with the
clipboard and sign people up for this
that and the other thing
they know that there's power in that and
they have the ability to make a
difference and i hope that
this generation watches it and feels
empowered and
pushed forward in that way and i hope
it's still relevant 20 30 years from now
yeah i just love how catchy the songs
are it just seems completely
mind-blowing that you can make i mean i
was like singing along to some of these
songs before the three minutes was even
over
so thank you for that awesome
i mean you know i think uh i'm glad that
you
enjoyed the songs and this is like the
best feedback on it because i think
it's it's a little bit of a daunting
task to try and like be very educational
in a song
yeah and still make it catchy so that
that was like the number one goal and
i'm glad that
that's that's uh the uh the vibe that
we're getting back from it so thank you
yeah definitely mission accomplished
both of you so thank you for talking to
me about it i appreciate it
thank you thank you